the titles of conferences waited for the
Bavarians and if we think in terms of
barbarians as the average television
watcher no people say that they were
barriers to people of Isis the people
are doing those terrible things but how
civilized is the West how to identify
barriers and are we civilization and how
civilized new consider Western societies
well I never bulls and people said the
moral civilization civilised West
engaged sub-object barbarians just as I
never both fukuyama's very optimistic
idea of a abilities I think the balance
of the games are the finale's
unfortunately they are every most
unequal States not with an equal degree
of violence but Europe has very systems
and European civilization contend they
contains some very divergence from time
to time it's not a bad idea
when you will give the keynote at our
conference we will have the pleasure
that will be published in touch as well
and I will say a little bit about the
plots of your home or will you keep a
secret this is a charming piece of
chamber music it's about three very
different human beings
a middle-aged woman and they young
idealistic students who better to spend
one winter under the city and they
stopped is fierce and feminists because
he represented defense where things
defend those my experiences and the
Iraqis toward the end of the moment they
were stubborn I say this very carefully
they almost love now in many senses this
is a result and open their mouths
treason through officer and honest he
reminds the others that throughout
history many many people who happens to
be a we're labeled traitors by many many
of their own Confederates away from the
profits more than statesmen like a brown
liquor or shall they were or the
perpetrator or a loss of that so
sometimes a traitor is simply a person
changes the eyes
did not change any spice change chemical
exchange and chemical the standard
convention change sees I said three
feminists if you wish three antagonists
under the same roof for what we've done
but this is what slowly people there are
many many ghosts in this house I don't
mean this rocketing white sheets and
making funny noises at night but then
who knows his presence is very prominent
in the house to this Jesus brother veil
that father only the angry with us and
the ghost
to versus interesting
many many many years because the
character dress is for the last 2000
years
the chernobyl of Western never surfaced
in many European languages the world
Judis simply been straightened up in the
dictionary and in the minds of many many
many pins of meanness of simple-minded
creatures there is no clear separating
line between you they and us very
similar words and the distinction is not
so the novel tries to work to move right
into the capacity to change your mind is
that also part of the cure of the
phonetic yes yes capacity to change your
mind that even more they can pass the
capacity to see yourself then we in
which policies the capacity to see the
world certainly notes in the urge to
turn the other cheek to your enemy not
at all I am NOT their patience but to
put yourself in their shoes
okay for people who didn't want to make
up their minds yet so they do not know
if they should go to the nexus
conference yes or no what would you tell
them well I tell them that they're not
the bearer of a new book so from the
Holy Land
and so I don't have new covenant ever
dissonant about their posters I have one
or two a ballistic suggestions on how to
be a slightly slightly better human
being and the suggestions and window
exposed well useless album with the
painful story my parents and repeatedly
love for you which I carry by Jesus know
that you are 33 well to be our guest
thank you